Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件现在正在发生的激动人心的事。如果你曾经想过如何创造源源不断的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）主讲的“冲刺经常性收入挑战赛”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战赛旨在帮助你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家的准专业人士、心理健康从业者，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, we are celebrating the 100th episode of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. We're looking at some of my favorite memories as well as some of the things
这些原则同样适用于你。此外，还有由丽莎本人亲自送出的丰厚奖品。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一一小时指导的机会。想了解更多吗？当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr. Marianne Trent），或者查看我的社交媒体频道，或者给我发个私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，我们开始今天的节目吧。在今天的节目中，我们将庆祝《有志心理学家播客》（Aspiring Psychologist Podcast）开播100期。我们将回顾我的一些最爱回忆以及一些
that didn't run quite so smoothly, as well as thinking about the future of the podcast. Thank you so much for being a loyal listener please do tell your friends about us and i hope you enjoy this episode if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that's your side to be on your way to being qualified Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I'm a qualified clinical psychologist. You join me on what is a very monumental episode. This is episode 100 and I was just doing a few calculations that I realized that when this episode is going live, which will be the 6th
进展得没那么顺利的事情，并展望播客的未来。非常感谢你一直以来的忠实聆听，请务必把我们推荐给你的朋友，希望你能喜欢这一期节目。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这个播客指引你前行，助你踏上取得专业资格的道路。嗨，欢迎来到《有志心理学家播客》。我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名职业临床心理学家。欢迎大家收听这个具有重大意义的里程碑式节目。这是第100期节目，我刚才简单计算了一下，我意识到当这期节目上线时，也就是2023年11月6日
of November 2023, that will be 23 months since I recorded the first episodes and they landed on Christmas Eve 2021. So we've packed quite a lot in over the last 100 episodes and I just wanted to say a big thank you. I wanted to use today to think with you about the future of the podcast, to think with you about some of my highlights, to think with you about some of the things that are coming up but also of course to weave in some useful and interesting nuggets for your own reflection, for your own growth. So it has felt like so long since it's just been a solo episode. But today is exactly what that is. That's happened because over the summer, I had loads of great guests I wanted to speak to. But recording with them is quite tricky when I've got a house full of noisy children.
距离我录制第一期节目并于2021年平安夜发布已经过去23个月了。所以在过去的100期节目里，我们涵盖了非常多的内容，我只想表达由衷的感谢。我想借今天和大家一起思考播客的未来，回顾我的一些精彩瞬间，了解即将到来的新内容，当然，也少不了融入一些实用有趣的干货，供大家反思和成长。感觉已经有很长时间没有做纯单人独白节目了。但今天的节目正是如此。之所以这样，是因为在夏天，我有好多想采访的优秀嘉宾。但是，当家里挤满了吵闹的孩子时，和他们录音实在是太难了。
So I scheduled all of those in for September and October, which means that I've had loads of great guests for you. But I haven't seen you one to one for a while other than the Galway episode. But that didn't really count because that was lots of fun and games and people that I met along the way as well. So given that today is the 6th of November if you are listening to this on the day that it's released then tomorrow Tuesday the 7th of November is the third and final compassionate Q&A or the application season. So of course, in psychology, we have those two quite distinct seasons. We've got the application season and the interview season. And I do do the free Q&As to support both of those. And then of course, the other season is out to fallow over the summer where you rest and recharge. And I try to leave you to your own devices then, apart from obviously listening to the podcast.
所以我把这些采访都安排在了9月和10月，这意味着我为大家准备了许多优秀的嘉宾访谈。但除了戈尔韦（Galway）那期节目外，我已经有一段时间没有和大家进行一对一的交流了。不过那期其实算不上，因为那里面充满了各种好玩的活动，还有我在路上遇到的人们。鉴于今天是11月6日，如果你是在节目发布的当天收听，那么明天——11月7日星期二，将是申请季的第三场也是最后一场富有同理心的问答直播。当然，在心理学领域，我们有两个非常分明的时期。我们有申请季和面试季。我确实会举办免费的答疑活动来支持这两个时期。当然，另一个时期就是夏天的休耕期，供大家休息和充电。然后我就会尽量让你们自己去过暑假，当然，除了听播客之外。
So, yeah, you can watch live, but that will also be available as a replay on Tuesday the 7th. From Tuesday the 7th, you can watch it on replay by going to my YouTube, Dr. Marianne Trent. Please do subscribe whilst you're there, like a few pieces of content, maybe chuck me in a few comments and share any useful content with your friends too. That would be marvellous. But you can also join me live on the night. You can join me from LinkedIn. You can join me from YouTube, from my Facebook page, which is Dr. Marianne Trent, from X, formerly known as Twitter, Dr. Marianne Trent. Although if you're joining me from Twitter, I don't believe I can see your comments as you make them live. So you may want to pick one of the other platforms. And if I can make it work on the evening, I will try to live stream from Instagram using my phone as well.
所以，是的，你可以观看直播，但它也会在11月7日星期二提供回放。从11月7日开始，你可以通过访问我的YouTube频道“Dr. Marianne Trent”观看回放。请顺便订阅一下，点赞一些内容，也许还可以给我留几个评论，并把任何有用的内容分享给你的朋友。那就太棒了。当然，你也可以在当晚加入我的直播。你可以通过领英（LinkedIn）加入，可以从YouTube加入，可以从我的Facebook主页（Dr. Marianne Trent）加入，也可以从X（原名推特Twitter，Dr. Marianne Trent）加入。不过，如果你是从推特加入的话，我好像没法实时看到你的评论。所以你可能想选择其他平台。如果当晚技术允许的话，我也会尝试用手机在Instagram上进行直播。
If you've got any questions for me in advance, look out for the events that will be created on those platforms within seven days before the event, because it doesn't let you schedule it before that, unfortunately. So there should be events that you can duck into right now and ask any questions in advance. Otherwise, just rock up and ask me your questions on the day. What sometimes helps is if you want me to know who you are and to use your name, if you go along to streamyard.com, either forward slash Facebook or forward slash LinkedIn, then you can give it your permissions so that I can see your name. Got to love a bit of GDPR, haven't you? It will also be streamed live via my Facebook group, which is the Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent. And of course, it will also be live streamed to
如果你提前有任何问题想问我，请留意活动开始前七天内在这些平台创建的活动页面，因为遗憾的是，系统不允许在那之前安排日程。所以现在应该已经有可以参加的活动了，你可以提前在里面提问。否则，直接在当天现身并向我提问即可。有时候有个小窍门，如果你想让我知道你是谁并念出你的名字，你可以访问 streamyard.com，并在后面加上 /facebook 或 /linkedin，然后授予权限，这样我就能看到你的名字了。不得不爱GDPR（通用数据保护条例），对吧？它还会在我的Facebook群组中进行直播，群组名称是“有志心理学家社群与玛丽安·特伦特博士”（The Aspiring Psychologist Community with Dr. Marianne Trent）。当然，它也会直播给
my members in the Aspiring Psychologist membership, which you can join by clicking on the link in my bio on any of my social media platforms or by checking out the description or the show notes depending on how you are watching or listening to this episode. So one suggestion that I'd had for my very special 100th episode was to include more bloopers, some of the bits that don't go right. And yeah, I guess this might be a good chance to explain that recently, in the last couple of months, I have outsourced my production of the podcast because it was taking up quite a lot of my time. So I think until around episode eight, mid 80s, something like that, I edited every single episode myself. So I've learned a lot about video and sound production
“有志心理学家会员专区”（The Aspiring Psychologist Membership）的会员们，你可以通过点击我任意社交媒体平台个人简介中的链接，或者根据你观看或收听本期节目的方式查看节目简介或图文摘要来加入。因此，对于我这期非常特别的第100期节目，有人给我的建议是加入更多花絮，也就是那些没顺利进行的片段。是的，我想这或许是一个好机会来解释一下：最近几个月，我把播客的制作外包了，因为它占用了我相当多的时间。所以我想直到大约第80集左右、80年代中期左右，每一集都是我自己剪辑的。所以我学到了很多关于视频和音频制作的知识
over these last two years, but it's not my forte, you know? So I did outsource those. But it does mean that the bloopers, which I'd started doing, are now not happening because I don't get to see the bloopers anymore. Believe me, there's quite a few of them as I fluff up what I'm saying, but we don't have the bloopers showreels anymore, which is a real shame. But if there's quite a few of them as I fluff up what I'm saying but we don't have the bloopers show reels anymore which is a real shame but if there's any way we can bring them back in future we will do there was also another suggestion about interviewing people who'd been successful in the membership which I love as an idea I might absolutely do that in future, thinking about what people have found helpful, because I know it's a tricky thing to begin to imagine how helpful it might be. So I
在过去的这两年里，但这并不是我的强项，你知道的？所以我确实把这些外包出去了。但这意味着我之前开始做的花絮现在没有了，因为我再也看不到花絮了。相信我，在我说错话的时候其实有不少这种片段，但我们再也没有花絮集锦了，这真的很遗憾。不过，如果未来有什么办法能把它们带回来，我们会做到的。还有另一个建议是采访在会员专区取得成功的人，我觉得这个主意太棒了，我以后绝对会这样做，去想想大家觉得什么有帮助，因为我知道，一开始很难想象它到底会有多大帮助。所以我
will definitely add that to the research list for a future episode. I wanted to use some of today's episode to tell you what it's meant to me and to share my gratitude to you, my dear listeners, or my dear watchers, if you're watching on YouTube, because it's just, it's felt like a really lovely community to be part of. I still am genuinely kind of perplexed and bemused when people tell me how helpful they find it and how nice it is to be able to tune into someone either chatting to themselves about psychology or talking to other similarly passionate people about their journeys and the things that they are doing in the world of qualified or aspiring psychology. You won't have met him yet, but we've got an episode with a
一定会把它加到未来节目的研究列表中。我想借今天的节目告诉大家这对意味着什么，并向你们——我亲爱的听众，或者亲爱的观众（如果你在YouTube上观看）表达我的感激之情，因为这感觉就像是一个非常温暖、充满爱意的社群。当人们告诉我他们觉得这个播客多么有用，以及能够收听某人独自畅谈心理学，或者与其他同样充满热情的人讨论他们的心路历程以及他们在合格或有志心理学领域所做的事情是多么美好时，我依然会感到由衷的困惑和不解。你可能还没见过他，但我们不久后会有一期节目，嘉宾是一个
lovely guy coming up quite soon called Matthew. I could have spoken to him all day, but he's messaged me several times just to say how much he enjoyed what we did and how, you know, how helpful he'd found it, how interesting he found it. it and you know how you mentioned during the chat like he really likes the podcast like he really finds it useful um and it's kind of what I like is it becomes part of people's fabric of their week so because it's always out at 6am on a Monday although I am playing around with that a little bit with YouTube. As I record this, I did play around with releasing episode 98 with Jonathan Paddy. I did play around with releasing that early on a Sunday afternoon. So if you like a little early look, do check out Dr. Marianne
非常可爱的小伙子，叫马修（Matthew）。我本可以跟他聊上一整天，但他给我发了好几次消息，只是说他多么享受我们的对话，以及他觉得这有多么有用、多么有趣，你知道的，就像你在聊天时提到的那样，他真的很喜欢这个播客，他真的觉得它很有用；嗯，我挺喜欢的一点是，它成了人们每周生活织锦的一部分。因为节目总是在周一早上6点发布，尽管我正在YouTube上对此做一点调整。正如我录制这一集时所做的那样，我尝试过提前在周日下午发布与乔纳森·帕迪（Jonathan Paddy）的第98集。所以如果你喜欢尝鲜，一定要去YouTube上关注“Dr. Marianne Trent”以获取该节目的独家抢先看。这不仅是抢先看，而是完整版。
Trent on YouTube for a little sneak peek at the episode. It's not a sneak peek, it's the whole thing. But it's another way to get your psychology early. So if Sundays work better for you than Mondays as a release date, there's potentially an option there if I do continue to do that. But yeah, I love hearing your feedback. I love it when people leave me reviews, which you can do on Spotify or Apple. So please do do that if you've got a spare moment. You don't even have to leave a full review. Certainly on Apple Podcasts, you can just do a rating. But if you've got a minute more, please do leave me a review. If you are on Apple Podcasts, go to the podcast app, find the Aspiring Psychologist podcast,
但这是提前获取心理学内容的一种途径。所以，如果周日比周一更适合作为你的发布日，如果我继续这样做，这可能会是一个备选方案。不过，是的，我喜欢听取你们的反馈。我喜欢大家给我留评价，你可以在Spotify或Apple上进行评价。所以如果你有空闲时间，请务必这样做。你甚至不需要写长评。在苹果播客（Apple Podcasts）上，你绝对可以只给个评分。但如果你再多有一分钟时间，请务必给我留个评价。如果你在使用苹果播客，请打开播客应用，找到《有志心理学家播客》，
then click go to show. And then if you scroll down past about the first five or six episodes that will come up for you, you will then get to a section for rating and reviews. Once you've just clicked your hopefully five star review, you can then write a review that would be so gratefully received. What do you need to be able to be a guest on the podcast? Well, an interesting story helps, but in terms of tech, it's helpful if you've got some sort of separate headphones and a mic, but you absolutely can use AirPods or a similar brand as well, because that helps cut down any audio noise. So I tend to mute myself when I'm not speaking. So I'm constantly like pressing buttons to allow me to speak, which does of
然后点击“前往节目”。接着向下滚动，略过最开始弹出的前五六集，你就会看到评分和评价板块。当你点击了你希望是五星的好评后，就可以写下一条评价了，这将会获得我极其真挚的感谢。成为播客嘉宾需要具备什么条件？嗯，一个有趣的故事会有所帮助，但在技术方面，如果你有一些单独的耳机和麦克风会很有帮助，但你完全可以使用AirPods或类似品牌的耳机，因为这有助于减少任何音频噪音。所以我通常在不说话时会将自己静音。所以我一直在按按钮来允许自己说话，这
course mean there's quite regularly a time where I'm talking and I've forgotten to unmute myself. It's just the modern complexities of using Zoom and Teams and stuff, isn't it? I do record on a platform called StreamYard though, which is really very good. I do think it's a good platform. If you wanted to look into that yourself, there's a link in the show notes. So things do not always run smoothly in the life of a podcaster. I remember one time I accidentally deleted or hid the entire back catalogue of my podcast. That was a little bit panicked, but I did manage to find what I'd done with it again, which was a relief. I'd accidentally, I think, hidden it into another folder. So since then, I've been backing it up as well, just in case.
当然意味着经常会有我正在说话却忘记取消静音的时候。这就是使用Zoom和Teams等工具的现代复杂性，不是吗？不过我确实在一个叫StreamYard的平台上录音，它真的很不错。我确实认为这是一个好平台。如果你想自己了解一下，节目简介里有一个链接。所以，播客主的生活并不总是一帆风顺的。我记得有一次，我意外地删除了或隐藏了我播客的整个节目目录。当时确实有点惊慌失措，但我最终还是找回了我刚才对它做了什么，这真是一种解脱。我当时不小心把它藏进另一个文件夹里了，我想是的。所以从那以后，我也一直在备份它，以防万一。
Sound has probably been the biggest bugbear. We also changed from being an mp3 only podcast to being a YouTube video content podcast as well. We've tried to kind of roll with the changes and get a bit of b-roll in there but yes sound has not always been our friend. I think hopefully we've generally stumbled across a mic solution that works well for me as the host. But sometimes the sound for guests just hasn't worked. And even myself with this podcast set up, sometimes the sound has not been ideal. So I'm sorry. Thank you for carrying on listening. Yeah, sometimes there's short notice cancellations
声音可能一直是最大的心头大患。我们也从一个仅有mp3格式的播客转变成了拥有YouTube视频内容的播客。我们一直在试图顺应变化，并在其中加入一些B卷（辅助画面），但是是的，声音并不总是我们的朋友。我希望我们总体上已经偶然找到了一个适合我作为主持人的麦克风解决方案。但有时嘉宾的声音就是效果不佳。甚至连我自己用这个播客设备时，有时声音也不是最理想的。所以对此我很抱歉。感谢你们坚持收听。是的，有时会有临时取消，
because that is life, isn't it? But generally speaking, things have run pretty smoothly. So let me guide you through what being the host of the Aspiring Psychologist podcast looks like. So in terms of recordings, I usually record these either on a Monday morning or on a Friday morning. Although today is a Monday afternoon because I was already recording one this morning. And I do have to keep some of my Monday free to be able to prepare brilliant content for the people in the Aspiring Psychologist podcast. So I do sometimes keep the whole Monday free, but I use Monday sessions as a backup for people who aren't free on a Friday session to record. How do I find the guests? So if you are a long-term listener, you will know that I often hang out on LinkedIn. And as part of some of the interesting conversations I have on LinkedIn,
因为这就是生活，不是吗？但总的来说，事情进展得相当顺利。那么，让我带大家了解一下担任《有志心理学家播客》的主持人是什么样的体验。在录音方面，我通常在周一早上或周五早上录制。不过今天是个周下午，因为我今天早上已经录过一期了。而且我必须保留一部分周一的空闲时间，以便为《有志心理学家播客》的听众准备精彩的内容。所以我有时会把整个周一都空出来，但我会把周五无法录音的人的周一录音时段作为备用。我是如何找到嘉宾的？如果你是一位老听友，你就会知道我经常在领英（LinkedIn）上出没。作为我在领英上进行的各种有趣对话的一部分，
if I think it would make an interesting episode, I do sometimes just say, how would you fancy coming on to discuss this as an episode on the Aspiring Psychologist podcast? Some people run a mile, but most do say, gosh, that would be amazing. Thank you. I'm very excited. Once it's in the can, so to speak, I download it and I create the little, the moving graphic that you will see that appears on YouTube, which also acts as the thumbnail for YouTube as well. And yeah, I guess I'm trying to learn quite a lot. So as I've gone along, I've realized that you don't need to call it the title of the podcast in every episode, nor do I need to say what episode it is on the description. Instead, I should try and use as kind of a click-baity title as possible, stuff that people might actually be searching for or Googling potentially. So that's what I try to do. When I've got that ready and when I've got any social links that I need to share for any guests, then I send that to my editor.
如果我认为这能构成一期有趣的节目，我有时就会直接说：“你有没有兴趣作为嘉宾来《有志心理学家播客》讨论这个话题？”有些人跑得比兔子还快，但大多数人都会说：“天哪，太棒了！谢谢你，我好兴奋。”一旦大功告成，我会把它下载下来，然后制作你在YouTube上看到的动态图形，它同时也充当YouTube的缩略图。是的，我想我正在努力学习很多东西。随着节目的进行，我意识到你不需要在每一集里都直呼播客的名字，我也不需要在描述中说明这是第几集。相反，我应该尽量使用尽可能具有“吸引点击”标题的标题，也就是人们可能实际在搜索或谷歌搜索的内容。所以我尽量这么做。当我准备好这个，并且拿到需要分享给任何嘉宾的社交链接后，我就会把它发给我的剪辑师。
It would be really good if, in theory, we can get a little bit ahead again, because sometimes, certainly when I was editing myself, sometimes I was only getting it finished on Sunday and then having to get it transcribed and do the show notes. Sometimes it's been quite last minute, which is quite stressful. But we're trying to move just so we're slightly further ahead um when I had a lovely aspiring psychologist helping me um she was able to help me get so that we were like three or four episodes scheduled in advance and that last happened um probably we did it over the summer with the summer soundbite series but um yeah full length episodes were scheduled over last summer. And then she went off traveling and we never quite recovered.
如果理论上我们能稍微提前一点进度就好了，因为有时，当然当我自己剪辑的时候，有时我直到周日才完成，然后还得做文字稿和节目简介。有时甚至到了最后一刻，这相当让人有压力。但我们正试图调整，好让我们能稍微提前一点。嗯，当我有一个可爱的有志心理学家帮我的时候，她能帮我把进度推进到提前安排好三四集的程度，而这种情况最后一次发生，嗯，大概是我们在夏天做了夏季音频短片系列的时候，但是，嗯，是的，完整版节目是在去年夏天安排好的。然后她去旅游了，我们就再也没有完全恢复过来。
But she's doing wonderful things now. And yeah, she liked working with me as well. So yeah, we get that back. I get it transcribed. And then someone helps me to create the show notes. Because that was a bit of the process I didn't really enjoy which basically if you've never checked out the show notes do it now why not go along to the show and then for each episode there is show notes which will give you
但她现在在做很棒的事情。是的，她也喜欢跟我合作。所以，是的，我们会把进度找回来。我会生成文字稿，然后有人帮我制作节目简介。因为那是整个流程中我不太喜欢的一部分，基本上，如果你从未查看过节目简介，现在就去做吧，为什么不去看看节目，然后每一集都有节目简介，它会为你提供
kind of the overview of what's in the episode you can also look at the transcript for each episode should you ever want to. And then, yeah, the main chunks, if you just want to kind of skim read, you can see what topics are discussed at roughly what minutes. So that's what the show notes are. We get a snippet or a reel created as part of the edit. And then that goes up when I remember onto TikTok when I remember onto YouTube shorts but regularly each week my virtual assistant helps me to schedule it up on Instagram because my scheduling tool does not seem to like me I put in all the effort to get it scheduled and it just doesn't happen it used to but I don't know I seem to have lost my own recording privileges I do not know why so let's just take a little break here when you can hear about
该集内容的概览，如果你愿意，还可以查看每一集的文字稿。然后，是的，如果你只想略读一下，你可以看到主要板块以及讨论的大致时间点。这就是节目简介的作用。我们在剪辑过程中会生成一个精彩片段或短视频（reel）。然后，当我想起来的时候，它就会上传到TikTok；当我想起来的时候，就会上传到YouTube Shorts；但每周我的虚拟助手都会定期帮我在Instagram上安排发布，因为我的排程工具似乎不太喜欢我，我付出了所有的努力去安排它，但它就是不发布。以前是可以的，但我不知道，我好像失去了自己的录音权限，我不知道为什么。所以让我们在这里稍作休息，
a little booksy-wooksy and I'll be back along very soon If you're looking to become a psychologist, then let this be your guide. Filled with lessons and experience that will help you get qualified. So come and take a look. It's right here in this book. It's the Clinical Psychologist Collective. It's the clinical psychologist collective how lovely it is to hear that again it's been a while since we've heard the jingles for the books because I don't tend to play those in the joint episodes
听听关于一本可爱的小书的介绍，我很快就会回来。如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这个播客指引你前行。充满经验与教训，助你取得专业资格。快来看看吧，它就在这本书里。这就是《临床心理学家合集》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective）。这是《临床心理学家合集》，再次听到这个声音感觉太棒了，我们已经有一段时间没听到图书的叮咚小调了，因为我不太倾向于在联合录制的节目中播放这些，
because it would be weird if suddenly in the middle of the conversation I just cut to the lovely jingle guys singing. So by the time you hear this episode, the world will know whether the Aspiring Psychologist podcast won an award at the Independent Podcaster Awards. So we were up for three different categories, one of which was Best Jingle. Having listened to the others, I do think it is the best. So I do hope that we may win an award for one of the categories. But unfortunately, I'm not free to go to the awards evening in London. I would have really fancied that because it sounded quite
因为如果在对话中间突然切到可爱的歌唱小调会显得很奇怪。所以当你们听到这期节目时，全世界都会知道《有志心理学家播客》是否在独立播客奖（Independent Podcaster Awards）上赢得了奖项。我们入围了三个不同的类别，其中之一就是“最佳叮咚小调”（Best Jingle）。听了其他的作品后，我真的觉得我们的最好。所以我真心希望我们能在一个类别中获奖。但不幸的是，我抽不出时间去伦敦参加颁奖晚会。我其实挺想去的，因为听起来挺时髦的。
swanky. But yeah, I'm not free to go. So I guess I'll find out retrospectively if I'm a winner. How cool would it be to be able to say award winning podcast. So that's something exciting. Other things that have happened that are exciting is I think probably mainly because of the podcast, but also to do with the Aspiring Psychologist Collective book and the Clinical Psychologist Collective book, along with the free Compassionate Q&A series. I've been invited to do some psychology keynotes.
不过，是的，我抽不出空。所以我想我会事后才知道自己是否获奖。如果能说自己是“获奖播客”，那该有多酷啊！所以这是一件令人兴奋的事。发生的另一件令人兴奋的事是，我想主要大概是因为这个播客，但也与《有志心理学家合集》和《临床心理学家合集》这两本书有关，再加上免费的同理心问答系列，我被邀请去做一些心理学主题演讲。
So by the time you listen to this, so if you're listening to it on the day it's released, the 6th of November, that is the day when I'm going live to the British Psychological Society's Careers Festival Conference as their opening keynote speaker, which is very exciting. yeah how cool is that actually that's that's happening on the 100th episode celebration so that's cool too and then of course I was invited to speak for the Irish Psychological Society as well if you think that you'd like to hear me speak at one of your upcoming events please do get in contact with me. In terms of some of my favourite episodes of the podcast, so I know it's fresh in my memory but I did just have a ball
所以当你们听到这里时——如果你是在节目发布的当天（11月6日）收听的话，那正是我作为开幕主旨演讲嘉宾，在英国心理学会（British Psychological Society）职业节会议上进行现场直播的日子，非常令人兴奋。是的，这有多酷啊！事实上，这正好发生在第100期节目的庆祝活动上，所以这也太棒了。然后，当然，我也被邀请为爱尔兰心理学会（Irish Psychological Society）演讲。如果你觉得你想听我在你即将举办的活动中演讲，请务必与我联系。就我个人最喜欢的播客节目而言，我知道这还历历在目，但我主持戈尔韦那一期时真的是玩嗨了，当我独自一人录音和自言自语时，它给了我相当大的专注力。我认为最强的一集之一是我教大家如何更好地复习和准备面试及考试的那一期。我真的、真的很喜欢那一期。我也真的很喜欢……哦，有太多了。很难在自己的“孩子”中挑出一个最爱，对吧？但我真的很喜欢与阿丽莎·侯赛因（Alicia Hussain）讨论她的价值观以及作为一名穆斯林的身份。与黛博拉·金斯顿博士（Dr. Deborah Kingston）交谈也非常有趣。这总能让我微笑。我们讨论了在法医环境中工作、作为一个稍年长的申请人，以及我想我们还做了一些神经发育类型的内容。我
putting together the Galway one, it gave me quite the focus when I was spending time by myself to record and speak to myself. I think one of the strongest episodes is the one where I'm looking at helping you to revise and prepare better for interviews and exams. I really, really enjoyed that one. I also really enjoyed, well, so many of them. It's hard to pick between your babies, isn't it? But I really enjoyed talking with Alicia Hussain about her values and as being a Muslim. It was a lot of fun to talk with Dr. Deborah Kingston. It just makes me smile. We were talking about working in forensic settings, being a slightly older applicant, as well as I think we did some neurodevelopmental type stuff as well. I had a
在与伊恩·登普西（Ian Dempsey）见面谈论财务问题时真的咯咯笑了，而且他已经被邀请再次做客了。事实上我今天早上还见过他，因为大家特别要求请伊恩回归，所以你能在新的一年里听到他的节目，因为我们觉得那是开始重新思考财务问题的绝佳时机。当然，这完全是一种荣誉和特权。还记得当我紧张和胆怯到声音都有点颤抖时，我和露西·约翰逊博士（Dr. Lucy Johnston）深入探讨了构念（formulation）以及威力威胁意义框架（power threat meaning framework）吗？所以现在要在100期节目里选出最爱真的很不容易，对吧？但我很想知道你们最喜欢哪几期节目，
real giggle when I met with Ian Dempsey to talk about finances and he has been invited back on. In fact I saw him this morning because it was a special request to get Ian back so you'll be able to hear him in the new year because we decided that's probably a good time to start thinking about finances again. And it was, of course, a complete honour and a privilege. Do you remember when I was so nervous and intimidated that you could hear that I sounded a bit wobbly when I spoke with Dr. Lucy Johnston all about formulation and the power threat meaning framework? So it's hard to pick your favorites out of a hundred now, isn't it? But I would love to know what your favorite episodes
哪一期最引起你们的共鸣，或者哪一期让你们会心一笑，哪一期让你们拿起笔开始反思，或者哪一期塑造了你们在表格上填写的内容，又或是让你们在面对客户甚至是在督导时能够展现出的自信。我认为关于设定边界的那一期，也就是第80集，真的、真的很扎实。你知道，所有那些早期的节目也确实是从事心理学工作真正关键的基础。未来会发生什么呢？是的，鉴于我已经告诉过你们我录制了内容，这些内容将带我们进入新的一年甚至更远，我们不会随时停止，也没有任何结束的计划。我会继续坚持下去，继续邀请非常有趣的嘉宾供你们学习、与我们共同塑造、与我们共同成长。你知道，我真的希望在——我本来想说明年这个时候，但不会是明年这个时候，因为一周一更意味着几乎要到两年后了。
have been, what has resonated with you most, or what's made you smile, what's made you pick up your pen and get reflecting, or what's shaped what you've written on your form or the confidence that you've been able to bring to clinical experiences with your clients or even with supervision for that matter. I think the boundary setting episode, which is episode eight, is really, really solid. You know, all of those early ones as well are just really key foundations, really, for, you know, working in psychology. And what's going to happen in future so yeah given that I've already told you I've recorded stuff um that's you know taking us up to the new year and beyond um you know we're not stopping anytime soon there are no plans to end I am going to keep doing this keep inviting really interesting guests for you to learn, for us to shape together, for us to grow. You know, I really hope that in, I was about to say this time next year, but it won't be this time next year because one a week is going to be almost two years time.
我们将庆祝200期节目。我简直无法想象那会是什么样子，但当然，我想我也应该说，正是这个播客为我赢得了第五频道（Channel 5）关于继承纠纷的演出机会，这个播客就是他们找到我的途径。所以，你知道的，这是播客带来的又一个美好的福利，当我开始做播客时，我绝对没有预料到这一点。所以，是的，我会坚持下去。对我来说，这是一个相当昂贵的流程，你知道的，有所有帮我做播客的人。所以如果你想给我买杯茶来表示感谢并帮我承担一些成本，你可以直接在Captivate平台上操作，或者点击我任何社交媒体上的Linktree链接。一杯茶就绝对令人愉快了。因为正如你们所知，我很享受一杯花草茶。干杯。所以，亲爱的听众，谢谢你们的捧场，
We'll be celebrating, know 200 episodes I can't quite begin to imagine what that might look like but of course I guess it's also I should say that it's this podcast that got me the channel five gig for inheritance disputes so this podcast is how they found me. So, you know, another beautiful benefit of the podcast, which I most definitely did not see coming when I started it. So, yeah, I should be carrying on. It is quite an expensive process for me, you know, with all the people that I've got helping me with the podcast. So if you did want to buy me a cup of tea to say thank you and to help cover my costs, you can do that either directly from the Captivate platform or by clicking my Linktree link on any of my socials. And just a cup of tea would be absolutely delightful. Because as you guys know, I do enjoy a cup of herbal tea. Cheers. So thank you, dear listener, for showing up,
谢谢你们一直以来贡献的收听率数据，我都会去查看。你知道的，我甚至今天都能看到，就在播客节目发布几小时后，我已经能看到今天有95位独立听众，总共下载了111集。对于播客节目发布的前几个小时来说，这相当不错了。你知道的，让我们继续做我们一直在做的事，但我希望这也是一个自下而上的过程。所以如果有你想看的内容，或者你想让我采访播客的某个人，请务必告诉我。如果你能通过把我介绍给那些人来帮我一把，那就更棒了。所以，来吧，来关注我的社交媒体，
for consistently giving me my ratings figures that I check in at. You know, I can see even today, it's just a few hours since the podcast episode has dropped. Already I can see that we've had 95 unique listeners today and that in total 111 episodes have been downloaded. So that is pretty good for the first hours of a podcast episode. You know, let's keep doing what we do, but I want this also to be a bottom-up process. So if there's something you would like to see or someone you'd like me to interview for the podcast, do let me know. And if you can help me by introducing me to those people, that would be marvelous as well. So, yeah, come and follow me on socials.
来和我建立联系。请务必留下那些评价。请考虑走进我的世界，成为有志心理学家会员专区的一员，让我真正帮助支持你在这条美妙的职业道路上开启旅程。我感到无比幸运和荣幸，能够说这是我的职业，也是你们的职业，你知道的，我真的努力让内容尽可能具有普适性，这样它就不局限于临床心理学，但当然，对传统的临床心理学可能会有一些轻微的偏向，但是，嗯，是的，如果你还有其他想听我采访的学科，请务必告诉我。
Come and connect with me. Please do leave those reviews. Do consider coming along to my world being part of the aspiring psychologist membership and let me really help support you on your journey in this wonderful career that i feel so blessed and privileged to be able to say is mine um and yours you know and i you know i really try to keep this as generic as possible so that it's not just clinical psychology but of course there may be a slight a slight bias towards the old clinical psychology but um yeah if there's another discipline that you would like to hear me
发自内心地感谢你们，我非常期待接下来的100期以及更远的未来。非常感谢，保重！如果你想成为一名心理学家，那就让这个播客指引你前行，助你踏上取得专业资格的道路。这是玛丽安博士的《有志心理学家播客》。我叫亚娜（Yana），是一名心理健康见习从业者。我读了《临床心理学家合集》这本书，我发现里面关于各种不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历非常有趣。
interview please do let me know thank you from the bottom of my heart and I'll look forward to the next 100 episodes and beyond thank you so much take care if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that you'll say to be on your way to being qualified it's the aspiring psychologist with dr marianne my name's yana and i'm a trainee psychological well-being practitioner i read the clinical psychologist collective book i found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist
它让我惊叹的是，通往那里的路线竟然有那么多，而且并没有成为其中一员的唯一完美途径。这让我充满了信心，让我知道：“不，我并没有做错，”从而减轻了我的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就不会放下这本书。本期节目暂无评论。点击文字稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。
it just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me of confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I'd definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will be okay. But trust me you will not put the book down once you start. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这让我感到十分惊讶，原来有这么多不同的途径可以达到这个目标，而且并没有一种完美的方式成为临床心理学家。这给了我很大的信心，让我觉得我并没有做错，从而减轻了自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐你看这个，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。但相信我，一旦你开始读，你就放不下这本书了。这集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。